はじめよ。
チャンネル登録者が70万人超えたらしいな。
あ、ありがとうざーす
おかげさまで
70万人いきました
ありがとうざーす。
お前最近調子乗ってないか？
何時も調子乗ってます。あざーす
バキャローーーーー！！
ひいいいいいいいいいいいい
お前調子乗ってんじゃねえぞぉ
100萬人目指せ、100萬人！！
うう。。。サーセン。。。
さあせん…
せゔぇすしゃすせす、はい
サーセン…
まあチャンネル登録者70万人いったことは
(どうでも)いいことだ
うっす
まずはみんなに感謝する気持ちを忘れないこと
Ass
あとは、チャンネル登録者が多いからって
調子に乗らないことだ
Ass
あとはもっと俺を動画に出すことだ
うすうす
ところではじめよ
うす
コレからはどうしていくつもりだ
いや、まだあんまり考えてないっす。
とりあえず
とりあえず楽しければいいかなって
バキャローーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー！！！！！！！！！！！
ひぐうぅぅぅぅぅ(はじめ半泣き)
そんなんでいいと思ってんのか！？オルァァ
すいやせん…
おまえはな、このまま一気に100万人までいけんだよ
さっせん、あさっせん
いいかはじめ！
ass
お前70万人見てるってことはな、
日本中の人が観てるんだ動画を！
あ、そうっす
ass
あんまり危ないこととかさぁ、
無茶なことしてさぁ！！
子どもが真似したらどうすんだよ！！
あさっせん、さっせん。
いいかはじめ
yes
多くの人が見てるけど
自分のしたいことをやれ。
えっ......いいんすか？
それでいいんだ。
マジすか
え、いいんすか
お前は最近ちょっと無茶をしている。
yes, 確かにそうっす
なんか見てる人が多いんでちょっと
なんかプレッシャーが
やばいっす
そんなの関係ねぇ！(by 小島よしお)
ひぃぃぃぃぃぃぃ
いいかはじめ！！
ううううっす
お前のYouTubeチャンネルのテーマはなんだ！
「自分のしたいことをすること」っす
ソーダ
獲っす
だからお前わ周りを気にしなくていいんだ
us
誰が見ていても関係ない
自分がしようと思ったことだけをしろ。
ソースね(カエル先輩は目玉焼きは醤油派です)
わかりゃした
ただ法には触れるな
はっす
そして常に動画を見てくれている人に感謝しろ。
オイスターソース(醬油派です)
ブルドッグ(だから醬油派です)
あとできるだけ「危険なのでまねしないでね♥」って書いておけ
イェス
はじめよ
「もやし」と言われることはどう思う
おまえよく「もやし」と言われてるよな
イェス
それは嫌なのか
いやです。
あんまり、なんかいやです。
MО★YA★SHI
はじめ「んぬうううううううーーーーーーーーーー！！(激怒)かえる「ヒギャアアアアアアアァァァ！！！」
本日静岡県にて、YouTuberを本職とするはじめしゃちょー容疑者が、暴行罪で静岡県警により現行犯逮捕された。
警察の調べに対しはじめしゃちょー容疑者は
「身に覚えがありません」と、容疑を否認しているという。
尚、被害者は蛙坂恭介さん(32)で、搬送先の病院で死亡が確認された。